hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from oron
who's one of our commenters on the Telus
talks business blog so in September i
wrote a post about twitter and how i get
the most charming by using a tool called
HootSuite and this was the post that we
created and so just created a video and
a little bit of information how i use it
good value from it on my desktop and
especially on my ipad so you can check
that out if you want but down here in
the comments we had a comment here by
oren who wrote great post you tell us
should think of posting a similar post
about enterprise and business use of
HootSuite team to Simon's permissions
etc so it's a great question the point
of that video in the post was on a
small-time entrepreneur so individual or
if you have a small team and you're
running things yourself then that's
basically how i use it so for social
media I run my own social media and when
I'm doing Twitter I posts all my own
stuff myself so I was using it from my
own perspective of how a single
entrepreneur could do it but if you are
outsourcing it if you have someone on
your team doing it or if you're using
another service to help do it there are
a lot of other tools in HootSuite that
you can use to be able to delegate that
stuff so you're not doing yourself one
thing that you want to watch out so I'm
going to load my HootSuite here so I
could show you it's really important on
social media that that you have an
authentic voice and that if you're not
going to do it yourself that whoever is
doing it can really represent you very
well so I manage my own Twitter account
we've a over a hundred thousand
followers and the people who respond to
me and I write back to them it's
actually me so there's a few here that I
was writing that's actually me writing
so it takes it does take some time every
day to do it but I think it's important
way to connect with your audience and
you want to make sure that the person
who is doing it if it's not going to be
you really does represent you and your
brand very well so just a caveat before
you get started here so there are a
couple of options so this is the the
HootSuite program that I've loaded up
here if you click on your face so this
is my face but it'll be your face
you can see there's a number of
different options so all I use HootSuite
for at the moment is Twitter you can use
it for a lot of different networks so
you can click add social network here
and you can see a whole bunch of them so
if you have a facebook account google+
linkedin whatever it is that you want
people to manage for you you could add
here one thing I'm waiting for is the
Google+ personal account so if you have
a Google+ page you can put it on here
and have that managed for you but I
can't see an option yet to be able to
manage your personal google plus profile
so hint hint hoots we'd love to see that
if you guys are watching this video the
page i don't find as helpful so we'll
close that down so you do have a lot of
options to add different networks in if
you want to go beyond just twitter and
then here you can see that you can
create an organization so if you want to
have people manage it for you if you
want to invite people to your team and
then assign task to them talk about you
know collaborating on different projects
and also say you know here's who's going
to be doing what what programming for us
and what messaging then you can click
here start climbing with others and then
you can add some people to your team so
if you have a virtual assistant that
you're using or nuts or service that you
use in or someone even you know who
works in your office in this product
your team you can do that here by
clicking on this button and getting them
involved the home page this is this is
what we talked about in the actual video
itself and so show a little different
lists and things that have been updated
on a regular basis you can click on
publisher and this isn't something that
I do but you can do it as well it's
another great feature within HootSuite
it's basically allowing you to schedule
out tweets so if you want to schedule
things out in advance and say okay on
this day I want this tweet to come out
so you're not having to be in front of
the computer then you could do it
through HootSuite I use a different
program to help me with that but you
could do it through HootSuite if you
wanted to and if you're doing it so that
there's approval required so if this is
your team member who's logged in and
then they need to you know get their
tweet of proof by you before it goes
live you can have it a be required
approval before it does go live and if
you want you can have a come from an RSS
feed so an example here would be if you
have a blog and you want every blog post
that you have to automatically
we'll hit your Twitter stream then you
can add it here as an RSS feed and it
will automatically pump your Twitter
pump your blog post out to your Twitter
account too so I don't use something
else to do that but it's awesome to be
able to do that within HootSuite if you
want to as well so it's great for
scheduling analytics to different
analytics you can you know different
reports you can create and some of these
are going to be you know the more
analytics that you need the more you
know there might be some cost involved
with the two but there's analytics that
can be involved and then assignments
again this is you can create assignments
for people who are on your team and say
no I need these amounts of tweets that
go out and you can collaborate together
and either give them their own
assignments or if you're the one doing
it on behalf of somebody else you can
see the assignments that have been put
out here for you so it is a great way to
be able to do things beyond yourself if
you're not going to managing it yourself
i find HootSuite is a really valuable
and important tool to be able to for me
manage such a huge Twitter account and
do it personally myself and keep on top
of everything that's happening because
if you just go to twitter com you're
going to get bombarded but if you want
to also be able to delegate things out
and you don't want to spend a time to
learn it yourself or be too active
yourself then there's other great tools
within HootSuite to be able to do it if
we click on settings and if we go to our
account you can see the difference
between a paid account and a free
account so if we go click on hootsuite
pro this is a quick this is just a
HootSuite website and you can see the
difference here between the paid
accounts in the pro account so the free
one here that's what I'm currently using
so you can have up to five accounts i
only use one you get basic reporting you
can do up to to RSS feeds but you can't
do a lot of the collaboration stuff that
we're talking about but it is free so
you know there's a there's a cost
benefit there right then you can only do
so much is limited but it is free if you
want it to pay for the premium account
of the pro account you get more profiles
more analytic so RSS feeds more users
here it's only two I think you can pay
for more users if you need more people
involved than two again reports lots of
other features to it
that's 10 bucks a month so if you're
going to be using it heavily and you
need people on your team to do it for
you and if you're hiring somebody to do
it for you 10 bucks a month is nothing
to add on top of that cost or something
to think about I think this ended up the
option to add more users that here so if
you need more users into you can add
another ten bucks a month per so
something to think about I don't work
for HootSuite so I don't have a vested
interest in in this but I do really like
it as a cool tool to use to manage your
Twitter account and again this it's what
I use on a daily basis to help me get
the most out of Twitter and also not
make sure that I'm spending my time
effectively and not wasting it trying to
read through everything that comes in so
thanks for the tip Oren hopefully if
everybody watching that provided a
little bit more context and how you can
expand it for more of an enterprise use
or at least as an entrepreneur building
it beyond yourself and having a team get
involved if you guys like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes me want to do more of these for
you and if you have a question about
HootSuite or Twitter or another question
about your business feel free to leave
it in the comment section below I always
read those I try to get back to
everybody as quickly as I can so thank
you and you'll see you on the next
episode
you